how are you great yes are you really
though the truth is is that I'm really
gonna miss you I'm gonna miss you as
well so what was that last day like it
was a weepy boy that's there is value in
these motels my family and I have been
staying in a motel for the past three
years and I wouldn't trade her stay
there for anything so did you know going
into season six actually where season
six was going no Dan took great joy in
being like I know every one of those
anyone right I mean for a very weepy
last few table reads that of the
Scrabble
I can imagine because you know we're
winding down and everyone's just like
going through it for the first time and
trying to hold back it's such a good
season and we're lucky because Dan
always knew that we were doing six right
so every storyline is tied up so nicely
there's there are so many good laughs
but there are so many like punches to
the heart at the same time say hello to
all my new hashtag friends it's a little
word I assembled to consecrate my fans
who are also my friends okay friends
doesn't sound nice the coming out sort
of storyline was huge for fans you are
the only thing in the world matters to
us
and if David makes you happy then that's
all we care about it was incredibly
powerful to to read and receive so many
messages from people who just felt so
seeing and represented in that moment I
know it's something that Danone and all
of our writers took great care to
construct it was quite a special
storyline and and those scenes were
incredibly special to shoot their ever
talked of getting this crew back
together but doing something completely
different I talk about it all the time
to dances blocks my calls right and
won't return any of my texts so at the
end does everybody get a happy ending it
looks